when it comes to the Oscars I think that
in the controversy I think the best line
I heard was Larry Wilmore on in the
nightly show sinker which I don't know
if it was on the show or it was just a
tweet or on their facebook page or an
Instagram or on ground running but they
said that they'd be that inside out was
the only film was the one of the few
boos was the film nominated where the
where they actually had people of color
and yeah it it's a rough one I i just
posted that I thought that made that
that Mad Max movie was horrific okay I
just thought that was a I mean if it
empowered women on some level I good god
bless whoever the hell gotten powered by
that movie you know but I thought that
was an inexorable so I i posted you know
that because they were that was getting
nominated for stuff and I posted that I
like if you're going to nominate
something like that then you might as
well you know the job I would have
nominated straight out of Compton
instead and I got this you liberal
Jackie you know you get a backlash of
these people telling me that I'm in it
but I'm you know I'm just it's I'm doing
this politically and then I got a right
now schmuck I like this movie more in
the other movie she's got nothing to do
with politics I can explain like I'm not
gonna I'm not going to spend the time
explaining why i think that movies more
interesting to me than mad max so I
interestingly enough I mean they're
they're people probably you they didn't
nominate 10 films that didn't help
apparently a big chunk of the voters or
you know seventy percent you know
there's a big chunk already who were you
know
not diversified seventy percent or you
know white then and you know if you're
going to in and the other thing is is
that women are getting screwed all the
time in terms of it and then you could
go a gist to you know age-wise so it's
not just minority and and I'm not saying
and by doing that I'm not and then you
have the city I now have to explain what
I mean that is not denigrating the the
fact that the blacks don't have a right
to ask for you know their their seat at
the table but women have a right test
that's all I'm saying and and there's a
you know I mean in films are perfect
it's Hollywood you know and if we're
going to talk about that i mean i've
been bent over and by them a
million times so but i was still going
to go if I'd got if things had worked
out the way they were i would have shown
up at the Oscars did I feel like I was
crossing a picket line in part but part
of me didn't because Chris Rock was
going to be there and I've known Chris
for a long time I wouldn't say we're
close friends but we we've certainly
worked together on occasions and talked
and I think that gum and one of my good
friends Jeff Stillson works with him and
writes for him and I think that they I
think that the there couldn't be anyone
better on stage to kind of go after
what's happening that night than him I
mean I you couldn't have picked anyone
better and they were lucky because I
think they picked him before the before
the this occurred so i think it was good
i think i think he will be enlightening
i look forward to it I look forward to
same except i'm working that night so i
can't beat the a key I'm we're keen